a lot of the characters and maybe some
of the situations were based on people
you actually had encountered in Portland
and to what degree did you envision it
as this sort of portrait of well it was
it was part Shakespeare it was part
based on Mike Parker who was who was a
friend who was on the streets and he
sort of inspired and informed us at like
exactly what that was that meant it was
inspired a little bit from already
Mellon oj Walt Curtis sort of being a
street poet in Portland it was inspired
by Portland the size of Portland this
the type of kind of frontier street life
life that's still existed in the city in
that period like in the 80s and and it
was inspired by the to keep one of the
characters that was in Milano che
Raymond G and his young nephew little
George they were sort of the idea behind
my own Private Idaho which was sort of
an Angela my love kind of story little
George being like Angela Ramon G being
his older brother so it was coming from
lots of different places in the city in
Sutherland how on earth did you imagine
that again you could get a studio or fun
or any kind of funding for that I mean
in every possible way it's like a red
lacquer yeah anybody was a lot of red
flags I don't know I just I definitely
liked when I wrote the final draft I sat
down and just wrote exactly what I
wanted which i think is what a lot of
filmmakers do anyway I mean I think my
favorite filmmakers were always doing
that in particular Fassbender I think
today Wes Anderson is just like you know
he's just writing what he wants he's not
considering you know what's going to be
laudable but that said the you ended up
deviating from the script quite a bit
right during the shoot deviating from
the script like weren't there a lot of
kind of spontaneous well sometimes the
screenplay was very short like there
would be you know exterior cemetery day
scott favor is burying his father
the way he can see Bob pigeon being
being buried by the others and that's
the thing and it's a whole it's a whole
you know three minutes scene or
something so it was condensed but I
don't think we weren't really we weren't
really sort of doing the same kind of
thing that we were doing on drugs for
Kelly which was going off the script and
finding new dialogue
mostly because River was very into that
Keanu was left less into that so it was
like it was pretty much stuck with the
screenplay with what was what was
written they were there were certain
ad-libs I think but um but yeah but you
know I guess maybe deviating was the
wrong word but the script in some ways
was a framework for the production
process to then sort of find yeah who
wants in it and find the detail yeah and
we would we would you know spontaneously
do extra things I think some of those
that Frank James James Franco made a his
own version of the movie from the
outtakes called my own private river
which uses a lot of things that we would
do sort of like when we were downtown
you know like shooting on the street we
would just find things and they weren't
really acting things they were more like
atmospheric pieces and the time lapse in
the beginning of the film is is Eric and
I really just going out he had a camera
that he had developed he had he sort of
fixed up a 35 camera with a
intervalometer and so he was just taking
these intervalometer time-lapse pieces
off just sort of not really for the
movie it was for himself and I think I
was taking stills we're just on a photo
excursion out in the country and we were
talking about my um privado and as soon
as we sort of filming it we kept doing
the intervalometer things until the
producer Laurie Parker started
questioning why we were doing the the
time-lapse and we didn't really have a
good answer in the end it becomes like
his inner world that he goes into
between
you know when he falls asleep and Cometh
wakes up somewhere else but we didn't
know that's where it was gonna go so we
we we stopped doing so much time lapse
and was a week and we're doing a lot of
it so she shouldn't want to pay for all
that extra footage if we weren't going
to use it so that kind of started
without the film not being in the film
you know and it grew up to be in the
film